chicken wild rice soup
i shame you
hi i'm rachel and i'm a tasty producer
back in october the intergovernmental
panel on climate change released a new
report on the potential consequences of
global warming they found that in order
to remain at or below the crucial 1.5
degree celsius increase we would need to
reduce our greenhouse gas emissions by
45
of 2010 levels by 2030 and achieve net
zero by 2050. some of the consequences
of climate change would be the rise in
sea level
severe drought and water scarcity
the destruction of our coral reefs
and possibly even a mass refugee crisis
which is all pretty terrifying a study
published in the journal nature found
that western countries specifically the
us and the uk
would need to reduce beef consumption by
90 percent cut milk consumption by 60
percent and eat four to six times as
many beans and legumes in order to help
keep the temperature under a two degree
celsius increase so since eating fewer
animal products is a significant way to
help combat climate change i decided to
challenge six tasty producers to go
vegan for a week so they could evaluate
their relationship with food and its
impact on the environment my diet right
now is pretty
meat centric i have to say
i have been doing the high protein low
carb kind of thing meat was just easy
for me because i know i like the taste
of it i know it'll fill me up and i know
how to cook with it so it's kind of my
go-to i think what's going to be super
challenging about this is that i'm
married and my husband is not
going vegan he says he's going to
support me but it is always hard to do
something when you live with someone
else that's not doing it i think the
hardest part of this challenge is going
to be breaking away from the very
solid non-vegan habits i have day to day
well what i plan to do is go through
tasty's vegetarian paste and check their
work and imitate those recipes and enjoy
them i think one of the biggest
challenges will be basically seeing an
option of free food that has meat or
dairy in it and then recognizing that i
can't eat that i love that with vegan
cuisine you're highlighting vegetables
and fruit and grains and legumes and
usually those ingredients are pushed to
the side but they're so good i just want
to push myself to
cook impressive beautiful food that just
happens to be vegan i do expect though
to be kind of hungry
i woke up
wanting a starbucks double shot
and i went to go get it and then my
husband was like
that has cream in it you can't have it
and i'm so mad right now good morning it
is
bright and early on day one of vegan
week
i'm excited i'm coming to the office now
even though no one else is gonna be here
because we have the day off
and i'm here to meal prep some vegan
food for the whole week my plan now is
to kind of cook and prepare most of the
proteins and cook some of like the
legumes that way throughout the rest of
the week i'm just kind of tossing
together the fresher items and like
making a plate for myself i thought it
was a monday
it's tuesday on mondays buzzfeed usually
gives us food which is very nice but i
did not bring lunch today this is claire
claire is gonna give me her roasted
veggies that she was gonna eat for lunch
and she's gonna eat chocolate cake
instead chocolate cake
which i've got to be honest i wish i was
claire how's it going guys
it's great look at jordan's savoring
that pasta
[Music]
it's
oh look at this you're eating plantains
this looks delicious
[Music]
it's day two the vegan challenge first
day in the office and i'm having
breakfast
some vegan cashew yogurt chia seeds
granola dried cranberries so far so good
as i attempt to shoot a video full of
dairy and cured meat
great i'm having some of my homemade
seitan that i made on monday it looks
like beef but it kind of just tastes
like bread
so i kind of miss protein tonight so one
of my biggest concerns for this
challenge was that the producers were
still going to be working at tasty and
therefore surrounded by temptations
so i was a little nervous about whether
they would have the willpower to stay
strong this is the daily temptation that
happens at tasty this is the leftovers
table and there is a
giant
sheet pan
cake
that i can't have today see everyone's
coming over okay
no one feels bad for me i'm sorry i'm so
sad so we just had chef jj make some
chicken plantain nachos they smell
absolutely amazing i watch everyone else
just
loving it up there's so much temptation
all around every day all day and you
know obviously i know my job i know that
i cook all day but do you even realize
that we also watch food all day when we
take notes on videos you know
every day you can't get away from it you
definitely get away
what are you making i'm making fish and
chips and they are fried
too perfect oh they look i mean
and then there's just like oh actually
french recipe yeah i can eat so
i'm gonna eat one of these
today we shot a huge video for pate on
croot which is like a meat dish and i
really want to eat it because the day is
over so instead we like had a side salad
that i made for it and i'm just gonna
have that for dinner
dude i'm taking a walk down from grand
central right here to the office this is
park cabin in new york city okay and
there's a bunch of propaganda pro meaty
products i'm talking about like
sandwiches and burgers
from breakfast to dinner
bombarded with images of meaty and dairy
products it's everywhere like you gotta
have some serious discipline to be a
full-time vegan you guys are not making
it easy you guys are not that is
insanely
tough so even though the first few days
were a struggle for some things finally
started to turn around and get easier
i'm literally shook i can't believe how
lucky i am
that she's making this today because i
just didn't have any time to like
prep food and i was just gonna wing it
when i got to work and you know what
it worked out for me guys my luck is
turning around
one thing that's great about working for
buzzfeed is that they provide a catered
lunch twice a week that always includes
vegan options okay so here's our final
plates
they actually have a few options so we
have some lettuce some potatoes and
cabbage lentils carrots and let's make
sure you got carrots
i like vegetables you know that's all i
can eat i feel like i'm gonna be full
which is good but this is looking good
i'm excited it's day four of their vegan
challenge and i made some
mushroom walnut pizza so
get in there folks okay this is what i
can keep eating i'll be a vegan today
full time
so thoughts on vegan pizza making this
is great yeah yay thumbs up
hey everyone sitting down for dinner hey
hey tonight we made a curry a vegan
curry uh it's delicious yeah i'm having
fun
being vegan
now it was rough ever go i'm not gonna
lie very tough um but it's gotten uh
easier towards the end of the challenge
i decided to treat the producers and
order some lunch because i wanted to
show them just how many vegan options
there are out there do you feel you
could eat this for lunch a few days a
week instead of real meat
yeah this would just definitely be like
this is really good i could eat this
twice a week three times a week
five times a week
i'm gonna eat this every day it's still
a lot of hamburger and it's just
honestly it's so good to find out that
there's so many options you know that
you can eat beyond broccoli you can have
this
we went out for vegan food today it's
like our final day and um we ordered a
bunch of food i think it was the easiest
part of my whole experience so far and
there were so many options mac and
cheese that's how the machine packages
were really good but i really liked the
shiitake mushrooms that tasted like
bacon it really did taste like bacon
yeah what's nice is for me i've been
cooking all week and even though i love
to do that it was cool to not have to
worry about that and just get a great
meal today was a turning point for me i
was like oh this could be something i
could actually do a little bit more
so this week has really taught me a lot
about just eating more plant-based foods
and how it's not as hard or as
challenging as i thought it might be i
definitely can incorporate more
plant-based
staples in my diet and have less meat
i'm not gonna give it up completely i
just think i will save meat for like a
more special occasion i have consciously
decided to reduce my meat consumption
not eliminate it
but just reduce it because i think we
are overdoing it people we really really
are i definitely think it's important
that i make efforts to reduce my carbon
footprint in the future i plan on hoping
to make more of my meals vegan
deliberately and worry less about having
meat be a central focus of any meal
although i love meat so much
i am open and willing to cut down on my
consumption i love trying new foods and
i think it's just exciting to be able to
try a new diet and
maybe find things that i actually really
love overall i'm so proud of these
producers for taking on this challenge
my goal was never to get anybody to go
100 vegan but show them that plant-based
eating can be just as delicious and that
by incorporating even a few vegan meals
a week you can make a positive impact on
the planet
[Music]
[Music]
you